hey 42 here it takes around two hours to
boil an ostrich egg welcome to riff
there are castles for sale in France
that are cheaper than two-bedroom
apartments in Australia chopping wood
increases testosterone production by
forty six point eight percent which is
17 percent higher than most competitive
sports in the early 1900's a woman named
Dorothy Edie from London made
substantial contributions to Egypt
ecology after she hit her head as a
toddler and claimed to have a lock to
pus life as a priestess in ancient Egypt
ground up red squirrel testicles
injected into the bloodstream
we once considered to be the secret to
eternal youth by dr. Horace Emmett
one year after he announced this at a
Cambridge lecture touting his newfound
virility as proof he died of a cerebral
hemorrhage the longest place name in the
world is a hill in New Zealand called
this Walt Disney used many dummy
corporations to purchased a massive
amount of land needed for Disney World
what his plan was publicized and whilst
his first acres were purchased for
around $80 the last ones were over
$80,000 each in Germany there are fake
bus stops outside many nursing homes to
prevent senior citizens with Alzheimer's
from wandering goth there is a city
called Rome on every continent slugs
have four noses if two pieces of metal
with a similar composition such as two
pieces of copper touch in space they
instantly become one this process is
known as cold welding according to a
study performed by Pew Research in 2010
atheists knew more in general about
different religions than religious
people did with Jews coming in a close
second and Mormont in third place the
male scorpion fly gets other males to
bring him food by imitating a female fly
a crocodile cannot stick out its tongue
one of the early names for Iceland while
snowland another was bottle and in March
of 2014 an unnamed British sniper in
Afghanistan killed six insurgents with a
single bullet he hit the target from 850
meters away which was a trigger switch
of a suicide bomber whose device then
exploded thereby preventing a major
attack by the Taliban thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2
you